how are you doing
i'm good i'd like i hope that this like
interview with a vampire aesthetic works
for you
like this is all the light that i have
but you know it's my thing
i don't know if it's your thing but like
i'm cool with it what's funny is i have
a red curtain behind me that i usually
use
for all my interviews and today i just
said effort and i just moved it up
because um
it doesn't matter um so i want to start
with how much i enjoyed this series and
your performance
in it um the best compliment i can give
is that it's
seven episodes and if it had been 10 i
would have been just as happy
i would have kept watching you know what
i mean yes thank you
thank you so switching subjects a little
bit
i'm going to start with a question from
someone you know
his name is edgar and um he wants to
know
uh how do you feel about the kinks as a
band
of course he does um that's so funny we
were literally just texting about it i
am obsessed with the kinks i love the
kinks um edgar and i share that
beth and i share that and actually the
reason that he's asking that is because
um so scott
originally in this show had a monologue
where beth like
waxes poetic about how the kinks were
gonna last like
or stand the test of time and that like
they're so much better than everybody
else
and scott like knew how attached to that
i was because i think the kings don't
get nearly as much recognition as they
should
and um he had to call me to apologize
when he cut it and i was like
i understand but oh that that hurt
they needed their moment i thought well
this is when you
call scott and say look netflix has the
ability to show deleted scenes
and if you if you have to include just
one can it please be this one
get it please actually so like i i mean
beth does sing she's
uh she sings um stop you're solving
so like why do you get to sing a little
bit of the kinks um
and that was that was worth it for me
but yeah oh i love edgar
that's sweet these are what we call some
random softball questions i promise
they're not hard-hitting i've been
asking this
okay yeah i'm asking this of everybody
um
what tv series would you love to guest
star on this is gonna seem super random
and i have no idea what i would do but
like the great british bake off
like just to show up i don't bake and
yet
some like for some reason when i was
living with beth
i would just binge that show because
there was something so beautiful about
the fact that like the worst thing that
could happen was like they burnt the
sugar
like that was it um so yeah i'd like to
show up on like the great british bank
uh what movie do you think you've seen
the most well most famous
the theatrical cut or the extended gut
extended cut
okay sure obviously um
jumanji and for my dad like
um top gun my dad was obsessed with top
gun we watched that movie like every
friday for
months so you're basically counting the
days to see the sequel
i want to take my dad to see it i hope
everything like works out so that can
happen but that would make me very happy
what is the last thing you've been
really obsessed with
it never went away pagan mythology
fascinated by it
um and with what i'm working on right
now it's like
very much part of the topic of what
we're all talking about so it works
do you remember your first movie or tv
show crush
the cartoon version of peter pan who
actually had
beth's hair i hadn't thought about that
but they have the same hair color
and cut um
that's really i have not yeah you're
right yeah
yeah i've heard other people say
uh animated characters and um yeah
there's nothing wrong with that no i
love them still do
yeah um do you have you seen any tv
series all the way through
more than once breaking bad
just something like just as a visual you
know like master class intention
like it's even if you know what's going
to happen it's still fascinating to
watch how they did it
yeah no it's that's brilliant filmmaking
brilliant filmmaker
um so uh jumping into why i get to talk
to you today
uh this is a role that gets you get to
showcase so much in it and it's such a
juicy role
i'm very curious how much you paid to be
in it
i mean i gave my soul does that count
like i feel like
i feel like i left my soul out there um
scott actually says he's like i'm very
grateful that like anya let me exploit
her growth for this show and i was like
dude the amount of healing i did on this
movie like
or the show sorry um yeah it was
there was a lot of me and beth and a lot
of beth and me
and we went on a journey together and
i've never like
i've never had such a connection with a
character where like if they were having
a bad day i was having a bad day and
learning
how to understand that that wasn't your
stuff
but it didn't mean that you weren't
gonna experience it um
was a trip well that's what i actually
wanted to ask you about i've spoken to a
lot of actors
and some talk about how there's like a
piece of them
that of the piece of the character that
comes home with them through the entire
shoot
and it can sometimes take a little while
after you rap
to find yourself again um how was it
how has it been for you as an actor with
the roles you've taken on
in terms of being able to sort of switch
it off
and you know what i mean like know who
you like
i think prior to um
this experience i was like semi
saved because the way that i mean we've
spoken about this before but like the
way that i've worked it's not been
normal it's been like i've just made a
movie jumped into another movie jumped
into another movie jumped into another
movie and so i've had to
release a character in order to be able
to embody the new one
um so it's like it gets ripped away from
you in a way
um but for beth
i like i knew 2019 i
for the first time ever in my life i
knew that i was going to make emma i was
going to have a day off i was going to
make
last night in soho have a day off and
then play beth
and i felt beth so intensely immediately
that i was like
okay this year is an exercise and going
wait your turn lady like i will come and
play you and i will come and like
pick up whatever it is that we have to
go through but i first have to be these
other people first
um so the second i stepped on set i was
like
okay there's no separation here
i just have to show up and
basically breathe and be alive because i
can
feel this person so intensely so by the
end of it like
i cried my eyes out but i was also like
ready
if that makes sense uh completely
uh i'm i'm i think you were probably
thinking scott please don't have me come
back for reshoots
no i mean i actually i do love reshoots
my first experience with reshoots was
with thomason
and i hadn't understood uh that
characters were real
until i was no longer playing her and so
having the opportunity to go back and
like actually say
like say goodbye was um was very
important to me so i never mind reshoots
it's always nice to go back and visit
one of the things that i really loved
about this series
is that there's no uh typical villain in
it
you know none of the guys are trying to
stop you there's no
you know the mom like your mom in the
film is not trying to stop
well anyway uh there's just no typical
villain and it's it's
refreshing and you know it's your
character up against
herself um you sort of talk about that
aspect that you're
you know that there's no it's just
unusual and it's nice
i think potentially that's very true of
life like most people's worst enemies
it's not like they have like this arch
nemesis that rises up from the ashes to
be like i want to you know
screw you over um i think most people's
worst enemy is themselves
is their self-destructive tendencies is
their self-limiting beliefs
is the way that they communicate with
themselves and
often that can be very negative and i
felt like
actually through playing beth i learned
to be so much kinder to myself because i
was watching her
punish herself consistently and i was
like dude just
chill out like you don't deserve this
like you're not the worst person in the
world and so by
proxy i sort of took some of that home
with me the interesting thing about this
is that there's no
the the action sequences in this series
are the chess matches
and it's not you fighting with a sword
or learning kicks it's learning
how do i move a chess piece on a board
um
correctly so can you sort of talk about
the fact that it is
those are the the action set pieces and
how you had to train for these
absolutely i had like a wonderful vision
of how this was gonna work out and i was
like
i'm gonna get so good at chess i'm gonna
spend all of this time
training with my sensei bruce pandolfini
who's amazing
um and like a chess god uh
and then the reality of shooting two
other projects before you shoot this one
is like
there's no time to do that um but i
loved it because my training as a dancer
actually really helped me because i saw
it as like
dance choreography for your fingers um
and i'm good at remembering steps so i
would learn all of the matches like five
minutes prior
to doing it and then just like use all
of my short term memory to
figure that one out and then just like
spin that game
and learn the next one and the the most
fun i was actually just talking about it
with thomas
um the most fun was the speed chess
because the amount
of intricate signal like little moves
that you are making on three different
boards and the fact that you're trying
to do it as fast as possible
it really fired up my competitive streak
with myself
and like i don't think i've ever been
more proud
like that was a moment where i was
genuinely like
don't know how that happened but it did
and it's captured on film and i can
sleep well tonight
amazing right um those sequences are
just so well done
um and this brings me into uh working
with scott frank
um i think he's such a gifted writer and
director
um i would imagine you went in thinking
one thing maybe about him
perhaps what surprised you about
collaborating with him on set something
maybe
you weren't expecting oh i've been
look i've been very very lucky with the
people that i've
um worked with and a lot of them have
been
you know i love directors but a lot of
them have sort of taken a
a different place in my life it's like
yes we made a project together but then
they do become sort of mentors or
they've really supported me and i think
actually from the second i met scott i
was like he can't be this nice
he can't care about me this much like he
can't like
he can't be this guy this guy doesn't
exist and genuinely it's him
like it's he has been so supportive
in everything to do with work and
everything personally he was like
one of the first people that really
truly cared about
like me as a person and not just like
what i was giving to him
um and he's so incredibly
um pushy on like
getting me to take a seat at the table
like he really was just like
no like you deserve this seat tell me
what you really think and let's
collaborate on it and like
create something together and um he
taught me to have confidence in my voice
and uh i'd love him for that he's just a
great human and
so talented he's so talented um
and it's nice to know that somebody like
that can actually exist
yeah um i've heard that from everyone um
uh
i i definitely i couldn't be more
excited about northman
um it's just something that means i'm
just very very excited
um i'm very curious how it's been going
and what can you tell people about it
um if you and i were having like coffee
or a drink i would tell you so much more
than this situation
um but let's see what i can say within
this platform
um i am over the moon
to be with like who i consider to be my
man
like i have like robert and i have now
been friends longer than we've been
uh co-workers and getting the
opportunity to create
art again together is just amazing like
incredible and we've both grown so much
apart and now we get to grow back
together and it's
it's so beautiful um i will say that
i am so proud to be a part of this
project
um every moment on set i'm proud and i
think
we will be presenting the world with
something like it genuinely hasn't seen
before
and i i just feel like
so um so genuinely humbled that i get to
be a part of it
he told me he was planning on doing very
realistic situations
very realistic everything um and that's
one of the other reasons why i'm so
excited for the project it's robert
eggers like
it's it's it's gonna you know um
something that was said a lot uh the
first day on set which i loved
because obviously you know like we we
made the witch like thinking kind of
that no one was ever going to see
it and so the fact that like we're
making a robert eggers movie is now a
thing we're both just like
this is amazing um but yeah people
showed up on our set and they were like
okay so like it's a real robert neckers
movie and i'm like yeah you're
going to be cold you're never going to
be comfortable
and it's going to be amazing like that's
just the way that it is
yeah the finished film is going to be
i'm sure um listen i already got a wrap
um good luck with the rest of your speed
dating and seriously congrats on
queen's gambit it's really fantastic
thank you so much i always love talking
to you so i hope i get the chance to see
you in person at some point soon
hopefully when you're promoting northmen
or last night in soho
hey everybody have a great day catch you
later bye lovely bye